alguna pregunta para mí y las golosinas
que no tienen gelatina solo digo kits
muy bien no son veganos jubilee presenta
hoy contamos a 7 pecados
soy vega no soy veganos hoy de ghana soy
vegano yo soy vegana soy de ghana uno de
ellos miente si el grupo descubre quién
está mintiendo se repartirán el premio
si el mentiroso se queda él o ella se
ganarán todo el premio
el impostor
primero brandon que comes para desayunar
hoy desayuné alforfón alforfón caliente
leche de almendras y agua bien bien
desayuna alforfón sé que si lo hacen
pero al verlo a él su lenguaje corporal
y como habla yo pienso eso es lo que
comes desayuno alforfón todas las
mañanas y siento que es tan normal pero
todos actuaron como si fuese raro
siendo honesto todo lo como con pan en
serio porque es que soy nuevo con esto
he sido vegano por 5 meses es un reto
que me propuse una pregunta cuáles son
sus restaurantes favoritos
chicos si van al norte de hollywood hay
este asombroso es un restaurante cajón
pegamos y si sabes he ido tanto a lópez
yo escribí a mi amiga hannah de ella de
ella es algo si bien parecía que sólo
estaba hablando sin pensarlo y busca
jugar este restaurante favorito que es
mi favorito siempre voy a ver con el
mayor orden hacen taco bell cuento
anunció un cronograma pero cambio la
carne por unos frijoles también cambió
la crema ácida y el queso así no usan
huevos en sus en sus tortillas espero
que no porque entonces no sería vegano
no sé por qué me atacaba a mí no sé si
es por cómo me veo no luzco como vegano
porque eligieron ser veganos soy vegano
desde que me mudé aquí me dije que sin
presiones si lo arruinaba lo volvería a
intentar así que me propuse hacer los 5
meses y ahora siento que es más fácil
continuar porque es si no nos quedan 4
minutos pero para cuidar 200
yo sólo intentaba demostrarle su
utilización ya no siento carbón
convention
estaba tardando tanto tiempo así me
encontraría más información acerca de
nadie soy vegana por el medio ambiente
creo que la producción de carne y leche
contribuyen bastante a los problemas
ambientales y por eso decidí ser vegana
soy vegana desde hace 3 años algunas
veces leía blogs de eso y mi mente de
que tengo colesterol alto luego de una
sola vez lo dejé mientras más aprendía e
investigaba al respecto más quería
continuar me volví vegano por salud por
mi piel ha mejorado no como esperaba
pero pensé ya comencé esto porque
dejarlo así como tú podía hacerlo y no
tenía razones más profundas como el
medio ambiente sólo puedo hacerlo ahora
es necesario para risk y me va bien ya
casi llevo un año bastante igual a ti me
volví vegana por la crueldad animal y
hay muchas buenas razones para ser
vegano el medio ambiente y una mejor
salud para todos
sido vegana por casi 10 años en total
comencé cuando tenía 21 años bebía mucho
alcohol y sólo quería sentirme mejor con
mi cuerpo ya comencé yoga y me hice
vegana fui crudivegana por 2 años fui
chef crudivegana soy maestra de yoga y
ser vegano fue parte de una transición
fui pesca tarja no por 10 años y quedan
2 minutos
no es por interrumpirte pero si será un
par de preguntas más cuál es este
documental favorito si te ayudo con lo
de al volverme vegana a veces veía
algunos de youtube cuales sólo menciona
uno no recuerdo los nombres eso los vi
en el blog que les mencioné antes y eran
cual blog se llamaba era de esta chica
que se llama m la mire como no sabe cuál
blog no sabe cuál vídeo no sabe esto tú
no sabes nada lo vi en realidad virtual
de hecho ayudaron a alentarme y lo vi
como si fuesen primeros cielos
como las mochilas primeras rondas
dentro de 21
tenía un poco más de maquillaje y
pintura de uñas también así que yo
supongo que en mi mente lo usual es que
los veganos tiendan a lucir más natural
a estaba buscando alguna pista y me fijé
en la ropa y el usaba unos zapatos de
gamuza y los veganos no la usan
[Música]
eso me sorprendió creo que fui algo
tímida al iniciar cuando eran 20 robo me
puse muy nerviosa y pues en mi mente se
quedó en blanco y pensaba hay cámaras
aquí están todos mirándome y se acaba el
tiempo
segundo rumbo que tú haces o por dios
soy más vegano por la dieta que llevo no
sé pero típico de ser vegano hasta
abrieron los vídeos hasta los son yo me
considero vegano pero lo hago más por el
tipo de comida no hay otras porque me
gusta cuidar mi salud estoy totalmente
de acuerdo
asus escuela yo no uso cuero
es curioso tengo cosas de cuero pero no
las compró son objetos que se compraron
años atrás que aún tengo porque sería un
total desperdicio al desechar lo
importante es no comprar de esa forma
marcamos nuestra posición
círculo aún hay personas que se
consideran a sí mismas veganas incluso
si es por la dieta que llevan u otras
razón como el rango
sería alguien que es como yo que eso les
complicó así que chicos pregunten me
quiero responder sabemos si si no lo
hago en lo absoluto yo como lo era
cuando va la miel no es vegana creo que
me hicieron sentir que mi razón para ser
vegano no era suficiente porque no tenía
el mismo valor que las de ellos una
persona así que todos piensan en sus
amigos cercanos cuántas de esas personas
son veganas todos mis amigos me apoyan y
amigos ellos pensaban que era poco
saludable porque no estaba comiendo
suficiente
y tuve un horrible problema con gases
eso fue eso fue estuvo feo pero no pues
en realidad le haré sé que sería así el
que es hielo
me esforzaría mucho con las excusas y
diría muchas cosas sabes solo estoy
siendo real con ustedes
yo hago lo mejor que puedo cuantos años
ha sido vegano o no ha sido menos de un
año como ocho meses errores de taco bell
supuestamente es vegano pero él no dijo
eso él dijo que pedía un taco y que le
sacaran todo y entonces mencionó eso
después he visto youtubers veganos que
van a taco bell
para mostrarle a otros que puede ser
quedan dos minutos
[Risas]
también tiene obstáculos
creo que fue algo agresiva quiero decir
es algo positivo para este juego estaba
haciendo las preguntas más difíciles que
es en realidad cómo debe hacerse alguna
pregunta para mi favorita golosina las
golosinas que no tienen gelatina solo
muy bien no son veganas
pero no
bien tal vez no soy vegano no lo sé es
que no lo no
pensaba que si ya sabes cómo es cuál es
la tuya
sí lo siento
[Música]
no me parecía que su ética y sus valores
se alinearán con la dieta porque
normalmente cuando eres vegano todo lo
que haces se relaciona con eso
[Música]
adiós adiós para gracias brandon puedes
ir a la sala de espera
siento que no soy parte de la comunidad
vegana tengo un amigo vega no habría
tenido cinco nuevos amigos pero votaron
en mi contra así que si todos están
seguros de que atraparon al impostor
pueden terminar el juego ahora cuando
cuando le perdono para eso por qué
creo que ellos eran humanos y creemos
que sigue aquí sí creo que tal vez si no
lo sé le dije lo que pensaba y yo le
dije entonces no porque no lo sé
bien levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue en la caja
si la luz cambia verde sacaron al
impostor si la luz cambia a rojo el
impostor sigue en la caja y perderán
bueno todos estamos nerviosos así que me
siento un poco más seguro
yo soy el impuesto
[Música]
no puede ser acababa de decirle a edding
creo que es gay link creo que es gay
link estoy algo molesto un poco triste
sin dinero he visto muchos programas
como este la primera ronda al comenzar
es una prueba para ver si podía hablar
con normalidad y ver cuánto en verdad
sabía sobre el tema y pensé si voy
primero puedo hablar mucho y hacer que
parezca accidental solo quería que el
tiempo se acabara y funcionó porque todo
se irritaron y ya no querían escucharme
así que me ignoraron e interrogaron al
resto a este para mi familia para mis
amigos este para mí este para un xbox
bien me siento algo frustrada porque
podría haber ganado si tan solo no me
hubiese dejado influenciar por los otros
esto me recordó las otras perspectivas
del veganismo no creo que sea algo que
puedas ver depende de su
ideología y de lo que piensen y de cómo
ven el mundo muchas gracias a todos amd
en verdad lo apreciamos y nos gusta
hacer esto para ustedes
nos encanta digan que les pareció en los
comentarios y díganos ideas para el
futuro leemos los comentarios algunos
quieren que somos sólo una corporación
pero como sea chicos nos vemos y am
suerte adiós
jubilee vive intensamente